Let us look at a connection between
your class projects and human cognition.
Beginning with psychometrics,
psychometrics is the science of
measuring human intelligence,
aptitude, and knowledge.
Computational psychometrics is
the science of building agents
that can take the same tests of
intelligence that humans take.
All the [INAUDIBLE] building
AI agents that can address
the Ravens test of intelligence,
it will provide opportunities for
thinking about human cognition.
While we will be looking only for
how well your agents perform on the
Ravens test, in principle [INAUDIBLE]
psycho-metrics will also look at
the kinds of errors that AI agents make.
If the errors the AI agents make
are similar to those that humans make,
then that may provide
a source of hypothesis
about human thinking on this
Raven's Test of Intelligence.
It is also interesting to note that
people with autism perform about as well
on the Raven's Test of Intelligence
as neurotypical people.
This is a little surprising, because
in general, people with autism do
not perform as well on other tests of
intelligence as the neurotypical people.
Note that Raven's test of
intelligence is the only test that
consists only of visual
analogy problems.
All other tests of
intelligence also include
a large number of verbal problems.
Might I suggest that some of
the thinking strategies that people with
autism are better aligned
with visual reasoning.